all the way through Hollywood California
the dating capital of the world is my
son and here's your host Drew
I'm your host Drew and welcome to date
my son Jewish mom edition here's how it
goes
we've got three lovely Jewish mothers
and they've got three very eligible sons
and they are going to compete to get
their sons ID with the lovely Lauren hi
Lauren welcome to Dave my son thank ya
Jewish mom edition all right so it says
here that you're an East Coast girl at
heart I am a Griffin Connecticut Oh
Connecticut
it says you made SoCal your home while
working as an online news producer I am
you're gonna ask some questions you're
gonna get some answers then you're gonna
pick which mom's son you're gonna go out
on a date with sounds good
are you ready to do it I'm ready are you
ready to play date my son hi mom hi so
if you're stunning I read Coachella and
we both lost our phones would he be able
to get us home my son would so be able
to get you home you have nothing to
worry about
you know one thing his father could
always do it was oh he had planted a bug
on me because no matter where we were in
the crowd he found me and he got me
safely wherever we needed to go so my
son does that also what about mom number
two you definitely be able to get you
home he would find somebody charm them
into lending them his phone and call an
uber get yo black car 3x
you know
Society has an extraordinary sense of
direction he gets that from his father
so ABBA so Martin Luther King is one of
my favorite historical figures who from
history would your son have been um I
think if my son is such a great leader
and having leadership qualities and
always fighting for the underdog so I
think you'd probably be someone like
Moses to lead the people new freedom let
my people date son is such an
extraordinary peacekeeper if I'm really
thinking about it I would say somebody
like Gandhi yeah I know that's big
that's big but it's true even though
Eminem is still alive
I would have to say he really Revere's
Eminem I like it
currently Lauren yes give us your next
question so tell me what your son was
like as a baby oh my son was the
prettiest baby first of all what upon
him I'm telling you and such a love and
I really enjoyed breastfeeding and he
did too long number two well let's start
off with the fact that he was a ten and
a half pound baby what so he started out
like a three-month-old he came out and
the nurses were so astonished because
most babies heads like sloth he could
have like looked around the room like
this check
ready out it was indicative of how he
turned out to be because he's the same
now you know that sound that sound means
it's the lightning round each mom it's
exactly one word to describe their son
mom number three go um you need mom
number two special mom number one one of
a kind that's more than one word but
great sounds to me like you all have
very unique and special sons you must be
very proud
well there you have it that's the end of
the game now Warren yes which mom are
you gonna choose mom one mom - or mom
three man you all are so awesome and
your son sound great but I think I'm
gonna have to go with son number two
there you have it
mom number two son Johnny come on out oh
wow
there you go well there you have it guys
but no thank you
well that's beautiful looks like the
three of you make a beautiful couple
am i right match made in heaven guys
thank you so much for watching gave my
son see you next time